nowadays I smoke about a pack a month
smoke two packs a day if I'm working
both jobs at the same day then it could
be like three or four if I'm drinking
and then like five or six been smoking
since I was probably 15 I started
smoking because I was in a play my
excuse was method acting but deep down I
really wanted to just try smoking
cigarettes I went to college and started
drinking and just had an occasional
cigarette while drinking and it took me
here
I know smokings bad for me it's probably
something I'd want to quit eventually
but it's a lot easier said than done
I've quit for a few times a couple weeks
tops and then end up just buying a pack
again I hope to get scared out of
smoking cigarettes anymore and finally
be able to fully quit I'm upset with
myself that I have decided to pick up
this havoc and hopefully seeing the
physical changes to my face it'll help
me make a positive choice in my life so
quit smoking I don't think it'll change
your mind but it's worth give it a shot
oh wow ah I'm so old the craziest part
about it is it doesn't look like I have
makeup artist if singing I'm an old man
ah
that's awful lines around the lips will
make my lipstick bleed and I do like to
wear lipstick the looseness of the skin
gives it a very almost frail texture
well my teeth are absolutely disgusting
and I'm kind of taken back it's pre
bizarre if this is what my outside
appearance looks like just from smoking
cigarettes then I can not even imagine
what my insides look like it's kind of
depressing yes I feel like I'm an old
man after this experience I definitely
want to cut cigarettes out of my life
completely I don't want to continue
smoking I'm going to reconsider smoking
less or quitting try to make sure that
my body ages naturally and not super
advanced like this process shows a lot
of people say they only smoke when
they're drinking alcohol and that's
exactly how I started doing it it can
turn into a habit that you do every day
I still kind of really want a cigarette
which is how upsetting of ahold
cigarettes can have on your life it's
not worth it
you